So we have--
the hypothetical situation where
we have discovered this chick
weight data set that
exists built into R. It's
one of the built-in data sets.
So we have chick weight.
It's got weight,
time, chick, diet,
and maybe we've made some
plots with that stuff.
So we look at chick weight
over time, nice line plot.
Maybe we've looked
at the density,
and we say I want to build
a Shiny app with this.
I've got these nice
plots, and I want
to put them in a
Shiny app, but I'm
dreading that aspect of
going in and setting up
that whole UI because
that's just code
that I haven't written before.
It's annoying to
remember how to write it.
So that is kind of a use
case that the UI Editor
is attempting to
make a lot easier.
So we can go in
this project that we
have that's empty, except for
these chickPlots.R script that
has those plots.
We load the Shiny UI Editor,
and then we say Launch Editor,
and we give it this application.
We call it chick dash plots.
You notice we don't actually
have chick dash plots in here,
and what it's going
to do is recognize
that doesn't exist yet and
ask you a few questions
about creating it.
So you say I want to start
a new app from a template.
Choose which template right now.
We don't have that
many, so we're
going to do a single
file template that
is the Geyser app.
Run that.
And now the UI Editor
is up and running,
and it's running just this
simple Geyser app just
with two plots instead
of the typical one,
but it's an app that
you're well familiar with.
So we can actually go in.
We see now that there is
chick dash plots in here,
and we can click into
that, and we see an app.R
and we can open that up.
And this is the code that the
UI Editor is currently running.
And so we can see that if
we want to change stuff,
like say we have
our header here,
and it is spanning the whole
top, we drag it over here.
It updates, and we see now
the header is only spanning
the first column there.
And so any update that
you make in the UI Editor
is automatically updated
in the app code itself.
So that's nice, but what if
you wanted to actually adjust
what is being plotted?
A lot of this fun stuff in
Shiny apps is doing the plots.
And so we already
have render plots here
for distPlot and bluePlot.
And so what we can do is take
some of our chick plot data,
and grab this code and
replace in our app.R
this distPlot with that
code, and we can save it.
And you'll see that
there's an error.
We can check this.
It says it could not find
plot function ggplot.
So we actually need
to load ggplot.
So say library,
ggplot2, save that.
Another error.
Object chick not found.
So let's go back in
here one more time.
Filter out.
This is a classic error.
Filter is one of those functions
that exists in the dplyr
and also in the base,
so we need to actually
explicitly load dplyer.
Now we've been making
these changes directly
to our server looking at the
errors that are coming through
in the UI Editor.
And now we actually have that
plot up and running in our app.
And so one of the things
we probably want to change
is to not distPlot.
So we're going to
call this weights.
So we've updated.
Now it's not there
because it's looking
for the plot output
of weights, which
we don't have because
we haven't renamed it.
Go in here.
Rename it to weights.
Save it, and it's back.
And so we can
continue doing this
for a bunch of different things.
So let's go take this
distribution plot here,
and let's replace a
bluePlot with that.
BluePlot-- that paste
in there, save it.
Then there.
It's a little bit
confusingly called bluePlot,
even though we have some
orange-red distribution.
So let's do the same thing here.
Call this distributions,
or maybe call it dist.
Once again, it's gone.
Let's go fix it.
This, save it, back.
So you could see that
we could just continue
to make our changes here.
Let's call this chick weights.
Center, code is
continuing to update.
So one thing that we
might want to do, also
is we have this number of bins--
which isn't doing anything
for us right now--
but we're filtering to a given
number of chicks, in this case,
it's six.
So what we might want to
do is take this slider
and repurpose it to decide
that filter number for us.
So let's change
it to num chicks.
Call it chicks to plot.
And I don't think
we have that many.
Let's maybe set the
min to 1, max 2.
And start at a value that
is reasonable, say 5.
And let's set a step value
so we don't have incremental.
Let's say step value of 1.
So we can go in here.
We see that we actually have
this slider up and running,
but it's not hooked
up to anything.
But we now know
that we have created
an input ID of num chicks.
We can just copy that.
Come over here,
say input, input.
Dollar sign num chicks.
Erase that, copy
this, get rid of that
because we don't
need it anymore.
Save.
So, in theory, this
will now change,
but the classic factor
problem is getting us.
So it's not exactly
doing what we
want because we're doing
chick less than input
number of chicks.
It's not actually giving
us the same value.
And this has actually
happened before.
We did this.
Just we didn't notice it.
We didn't count the lines.
So we should go
into chick weight,
mutate chick, and start
numeric as well as an integer.
That might be right.
There we go.
Now it's all fixed, but
we can do all of that.
We can mess with our code,
we can update our plots,
and all we have to do is just
go back and forth between the UI
Editor and the code.
And so the idea
is you don't have
to sit there and fiddle
with this grid card.
What's the argument name?
Where do I nest this?
I want to put it over here.
You don't need to
worry about that.
You can just focus on
writing good data science,
doing correct plots, doing
your dplyr pipes properly.
We want you to focus
on those issues which
are straightforward and
not this crazy world that
is, how do you get your text
to align properly in your UI.
How do you make your
header a little bit taller
than it was before?
That stuff that
doesn't influence how
good are as a data scientist.
So we're trying to make
that as easy as possible.
Before we talked about
if we had a table, right?
So we have this code here.
So take that down here and
use output table [INAUDIBLE]..
We actually put
that table in here.
[INAUDIBLE]
So we go into this grid
card that has nothing in it,
and we say gt.
And it's like gt output.
So this idea of we
have a table in here--
let me make it bigger so
we can see the table--
we have this table in
here, but the UI editor
doesn't support it,
doesn't have it,
doesn't know about
gt tables yet.
And so what it does is it gives
you this little gray box that
says, hey, I have
this UI function
that I don't know about.
Here's the code.
You can't edit it because
I don't know about it,
but it is treated just
like any other node.
So you could take this
and put it up here.
Drag this down.
That's [INAUDIBLE]
your tables in there.
So you can treat it just like
you would any other node,
but it doesn't know about it.
And so the idea there
is that we don't limit.
If you have some cool
custom function or just
a function that's
not included yet,
it's not going to make it so
you can't use the UI Editor.
It just means that you won't be
able to use the nice UI Editor
settings panel to change
it, but you can still
lay out your app and
everything and place it
where you want within the
app and then see what it is.
So that will help.
Ideally, in the future,
every possible thing
that you put in your
Shiny app is known,
but I don't think that's
ever going to be the case.
And so this is how that
is treated in the editor.
So that's important to know.